serena williams's daughter olympia
taking the trophy as mom's number one
fan i love her so much and you know it's
we have a great little family going on
for what could be the tennis legends
final u.s open her four-year-old
daughter paid homage in the coolest way
not only is she mom's little cheerleader
snapping pics and rooting from the
stands
she also matched serena's sparkly
ensemble and her iconic braids i've
never a day without olympia like she's
my priority and every day i like need to
be home with her because i don't i don't
want to miss any moments with her yeah
you remember 1999 a then 17 year old
serena rocked the same hairstyle when
she won her first u.s open seeing these
two side by side absolutely serving yeah
we'll be over here making a racket get
it it was either her wear beads or me so
i wanted to do it but i just didn't have
the time so um
yeah she she likes actually when she
asked to wear beads a lot
um but it actually wasn't my idea but i
was so happy when she had them on it's
perfect on her but it's not the first
time the fashionable mother-daughter duo
totally twinned last year they showed up
in similar looks the premiere of king
richard the biopic based on serena's
dad's life matching outfits with mama
it's been great she's been a great sport
with it and you know this is a great
time but back to olympia's mama's big
day not only did the little one and her
dad show their support during the
exciting match bella hadid offset gail
king bill clinton queen latifah hugh
jackman and more showed up to cheer on
the champ
this is expected to be the last
professional tournament for the tennis
icon who revealed in vogue earlier this
month her intention to retire but
without actually using that particular
word instead she explained i'm here to
tell you that i'm evolving away from
tennis toward other things that are
important to me yes working motherhood
is real it's so real
but my priorities in olympia is that she
also told the mag she wants to grow her
family in the last year alexis and i
have been trying to have another child
and we recently got some information
from my doctor that put my mind at ease
and made me feel that whenever we're
ready we can add to our family i
definitely don't want to be pregnant
again as an athlete i need to be two
feet into tennis or two feet out and
that all echoes what she told et earlier
this year i definitely want to have more
kids it's just like
balance is key you know and just trying
to find that balance and
you know i don't know it's always like
okay are we ready are we ready so and i
know the clock is ticking so i'm just
like okay i need to figure out when
that's going to be but hopefully soon
we'll know we'll see no pressure right
[Music]